Hey, what day is it today that you can ask questions?It's so
easy that I'm wondering if it's the wrong answer, but do
n't get twisted and answer straight, right?
Valentine, you
might be able to give me the correct answer.  I had prepared it for
Valentine's Day, but now it's gone, so I
wonder if it's for Hirata or something.I'm not complaining or thinking that I've been preparing for Valentine's Day for a long time.It's been a nice fall and winter.It's something I'll
need even if I've decided to break up.
Well, I guess you, who have never
experienced love,
wouldn't understand that kind of thing.But yeah, I thought you
chose today because you thought you might get it from me, but I'm sorry, I
didn't think about that at all.  By the way, the other girl gave it to me.No, it's
zero at all.Zero seems like a
good-looking guy.But don't worry, if you give it to me, it won't be zero anymore.That's probably the beginning of it.I'll send it to you.I'll
double the thank you in return.  I don't mind if you give it to me. Is it
something like that? Is it
something like that? Is it Valentine's day chocolate or love? I do
n't think there's anything more interesting than that. No.